[Music]  so  [Music]  [Music]  so  last bin of vacation comics to be  thrown out of here moved out of here  and uh take a look around this is  jane formerly on the bob secret stash  here let me do one of these  the tony stark  [Music]  [Laughter]  [Music]  oh my god he's got six toes the [ __ ]  does he  that would have been awesome it's like  somebody messed up there  all right so if we're going off this  where's your truck  oh it's ready do you think we should eat  first oh  why are you you guys i don't know why  you didn't eat you want to eat you don't  start you're good  to drive because you're going to be in  the car from here  [Music]  me so hungry  [Music]  the new version where we take the buddy  christ  and we parade him from the old stash  to the new stage we're going to carry  the body price a procession  down to the brand new secret station  that everybody can be involved  [Applause]  [Music]  you